(soft music)
Bro, do you even nutrition?
Today, I'm gonna go over all the basics
that you need to know when
it comes to nutrition.
Calories, macronutrients, micronutrients,
weight loss, weight gain,
your questions answered.
Let's go.
In order for you to properly
grasp nutrition 101,
I wanna introduce you to a
very good friend of mine.
Welcome, to the Dr Mike channel,
Dr Mikes Nutrition Triangle
101 Education Basic
Thinagamabobits.
- I don't know what the
deal is with with all that.
- Basically, I have this
triangle set up for you guys
so you can understand the three legs
that are super super important
when you're talking about eating healthy.
Calories.
Now you've probably heard of calories
to some extent in the past.
A technical definition of a calorie
is the amount of energy
needed to raise one kilogram
of water by one degree Celsius.
- Oh.
- Let's just stick with
the idea that calories
are a form of energy
and it's found in food
and your body needs it
to function optimally.
Continuing on down the nutrition triangle,
we have macronutrients.
You may have heard of them
referred to as macros.
First up, we have proteins like fish.
Next up, fats, like olive oil.
And your favorite, carbs,
which can be cookies, bread, cakes,
all the delicious stuff.
- [Guy] Hey.
- Oh, and I guess, we have alcohols too
and that's the fourth macronutrient
but we're not gonna confuse
this video any further.
This is a really good time to let you know
that I partnered with the
app Lifesum* for this video.
It allows you to track calories,
macronutrients, your weight,
set goals for yourself,
set up delicious recipes.
Throughout this video,
I'm gonna be showing you
how I utilize it when I'm creating
a healthy nutrition triangle plan.
And you should definitely think about
grabbing the app for yourself.
All right, jumping back
into the macronutrients,
starting off with protein.
Protein's an incredibly
important component
of every cell of the body.
Hair and nails are actually
mostly made up of protein.
Protein is a vital macronutrient
that your body uses to build and repair
muscle, bone, and skin and even blood.
Jumping over to fat,
I wanna first tell you
that I think dietary fats
have gotten a bad wrap.
Dietary fats are essential
to give you energy
and support cell growth.
They also help protect your
organs and keep your body warm.
And finally fats help you
absorb some nutrients as well
as producing som vital
hormones, like testosterone.
Furthermore, fats break
down into saturated
and unsaturated fats.
But that can get controversial
and a little complex
so let's save that for
the nutrition 201 video.
As for carbs, I'm not
necessarily a huge fan.
Carb, don't worry I'm gonna
tell them the good parts
about you too.
Carbs break down into three categories.
Fibers, starches and sugars.
Fiber is an incredibly important
component of carbohydrates.
Not only does it help your gut bacteria
survive and thrive, but
it could also possibly
curb your appetite, lower
your cholesterol levels,
decrease some risks of cancer.
That's pretty exciting and
that's the part of carbs
I really do enjoy.
Starches are the most
consumed carbs on this planet.
You most often find them in
grains and root vegetables.
And then, we come to sugars.
You know what a sugar is.
I now what a sugar is.
Sugar get rapidly absorbed
into our bloodstream
causing a huge blood sugar spike,
therefore, an insulin
spike and that can cause
a lot of problems when you overeat it.
And because it tastes so good,
it's very easy to overeat.
We went macro.
Time to go micro.
The third and final leg of our
triangle is micronutrients.
Here, we're talking about
vitamins and minerals.
Vitamins classically, you
hear of vitamin B, C, D,
minerals like zinc and iron.
These are essential
nutrients for our life.
The reason why they're called essential
is because for the most part,
our body is unable to
make these on its own.
And we need to get them from our diets.
If you're low on vitamins, that
can hurt your energy levels,
your immune system, your ability
to clot and so much more.
And if you're low on minerals,
your bones won't form properly,
you won't grow properly,
you could possibly be anemic.
This is why these bad
boys are so essential.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Something you have to know
is that all diets are
not not created equal.
And I'm gonna run through
a single example with you
right now so that you can follow along.
Let's say there are two
people in a given situation.
They have the same maintenance calories,
and they're looking to lose weight.
Person A decides to follow the cookie diet
and they're gonna aim to eat
1500 calories of cookies a day,
which is 500 calories below
their required maintenance.
Person B is also gonna be
eating 1500 calories a day
but they're gonna be following
the Mediterranean diet,
basically a wholefoods, plant based diet.
Who do you think I'm gonna say
is following the healthy diet?
I mean it's obvious but do
you know why it's obvious?
Both people will actually lose weight.
So, you may say to yourself, well,
so if they're both losing weight,
why is one worse that the other?
Go back to my little
triangle that I created.
Both are eating a caloric deficit, check.
But person A is eating
cookies, which is mostly sugars
and some fat, so they're
not getting a great balance
of macronutrients.
Person B, Mediterranean diet.
Great balance of macronutrients.
Let's talk about micronutrients.
Probably the more important
point of the conversation here.
If you follow the cookie diet,
what micronutrients are in cookies?
Mediterranean diet, rich in
vitamins, rich in minerals.
Yes, we want you to lose
weight if you're overweight
and yes, we want you to
consume less calories
but that's not where the story ends.
We need to consider that
whole triangle of calories,
macros and micronutrients.
(soft music)
In the United States, obesity
has become an epidemic.
So, I understand why most
people wanna lose weight.
It's actually been proven
in the best quality studies
keeping your weight healthy
is one of the most important
things you can do to maintain your health,
to live a long life.
So, if you're trying to lose weight
or if you're possibly underweight
and wanna gain weight,
here's what I recommend you do.
Calculate your maintenance calories.
You can do that through
a calculator online.
And then if you wanna again weight,
add to the maintenance
calories and eat that.
If you wanna lose weight,
eat a little bit less
than your maintenance and
you're gonna be losing weight.
What I recommend to my
patients is that ideally
they lose or gain a pound a week max.
'Cause when you start going into extremes,
that could really mess with your body,
unless of course, you
have a medical condition
or working with a nutritionist or doctor.
To make life even easier for you,
I recommend you just download Lifesum*
and plug in all your information
and it'll tell you what your
maintenance calories are
or what you have to be eating
in order to gain or lose weight.
It's such a simpler process when dieting.
Let's use myself as an example
because I'm actively dieting.
I'm trying to lose some weight, not a lot,
but I'm losing weight trying
to try to keep my muscle.
I'll show you how I use
Lifesum* to make that happen.
All right, let's start
with finding your plan.
I wanna have a high protein plan
where I'll lose some
weight without going hungry
and losing my muscle.
So, I hit high protein, I hit start plan,
it allows me to choose how
much protein I wanna take in
based on how much exercise I'm doing.
Let's keep it in the midline here
and do .9 grams of
protein for body weight.
Some people say to do .8
Some people say to do one.
Let's keep it simple and
do it right in the middle.
Hit continue.
It says I should be
focusing on eating foods
that are rich in protein, I agree.
It gives me my breakdown in calories
and macronutrients.
It gives you some basic do's and don'ts
which is awesome.
You hit start plan, boom!
It tells me how many
calories I have to eat today,
how many I've eaten, how many I've burned,
how many carbs I have to eat,
how many proteins I have to eat,
how many fats I have to eat.
So, let's add what I had for breakfast.
I ordered out actually, 'cause
I was busy, don't judge me
but we got Muscle Maker
Grill, I had a wrap
it's called a Rocky Balboa Wrap, boom!
Right there.
Were gonna add it to the diary
and you can see right
here, you click breakfast
and it says, we have 59 grams of protein
with a little happy face, 'cause
that's what we need to do.
It shows you how many calories I had.
I should have aimed
for about 700 calories.
I did 646, which is close enough
because throughout the
day, it'll average out.
And then if you look back
onto the main diary here,
now I have 1500 calories left for the day.
It shows you my breakdown
on my macronutrients.
You don't have to track the calories.
You don't have to put
anything down on paper.
That can get very
complicated and intimidating.
You now have a solid foundation
in understanding nutrition
and what healthy eating
truly means.
When you're thinking about nutrition,
always remember that little triangle
of calories, macronutrients
and micronutrients
so you can decide what's
healthy and what's not.
Trust me.
There's a lot of nuance
when it comes to nutrition.
And I didn't wanna bog this
video down with controversy.
In general, the field
of nutrition research
is an absolute mess and we'll save that
for the future videos.
For now, I just wanted you
to have a solid understanding
for you to have a healthy
and happy conversation
with your nutritionist, doctor, trainer,
you got the basics, so, click here
for my diet reviews to
truly become a master.
And huge thank you to Lifesum
for making this video happen.
Stay happy and healthy.
(bright music)